[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As a
developer today, you
can launch solutions
faster than ever,
building on the
capabilities of Google Cloud
platform, your custom
services, and third-party APIs.
But as more and more
services are integrated,
your solutions can increase
the complexity, becoming
hard to understand, and even
harder to develop, debug,
and visualize.
You could write custom services
to manage these integrations
and host them in
manually-maintained virtual
machines or link them together
with a carefully crafted
event-driven architecture.
Even with event-driven
architecture,
observing the progress
of a workflow execution
is nearly impossible,
especially when
a workflow might run for
hours, days, or even months.
Implementing error
handling can be difficult.
When something fails
along the chain of events,
it becomes burdensome
to track down.
Plus, chaining services
together gives you
a growing distributed system
with less predictable behavior
over time.
Changes to one workflow
may break another workflow
also using those events.
Without a central definition
of the entire workflow,
it can be hard to
see the full picture
and make appropriate changes.
So how can you best use the
power of different services
in your custom workflow
without all of these issues?
By using Google Cloud Workflows.
Cloud Workflows is a
fully managed service
that gives you the power
to integrate microservices
and APIs while also error
handling and streamlining
future development.
From one central
place, you can describe
steps that combine custom
services, Google Cloud
products, and anything
with HTTP APIs
into an automated workflow.
And because it's
serverless, workflow scales
to meet your demand, so you
only pay for what you use.
So how does it work?
Let's look at the
two primary use
cases, event-driven
workflows and batch jobs.
Event-driven workflows execute
when a certain trigger happens.
For example, let's say one
of your e-commerce customers
has just placed an order,
and they need their invoice.
A new e-commerce event order
kicks off the workflow.
First up, a cloud or an app
receives data from the event
and generates a PDF.
Then, the PDF is
passed to a cloud
function that encrypts and
compresses it into a ZIP file.
And finally, the PDF is sent
to a third-party email API,
sending the invoice
to the customer.
Batch workflows consist of
running large jobs potentially
on a regular basis.
For example, a nightly job to
check on any incomplete orders
from your e-commerce site.
Each night at midnight,
the workflow is kicked off.
The database is queried
for any incomplete orders
in the past 24 hours.
Each valid account is sent
to a cloud function that can
generate a personalized offer.
The offer is sent to a separate
function to generate an email.
And those emails are sent
using the same third-party API.
In both cases, Workflow
gives you a holistic approach
to workflow management.
From the user interface or
from your favorite editor,
you can build custom
workflows and investigate
ones that are already running.
When calling other
Google Cloud services,
Workflow handles all
the underlying details,
like transport
authentication and waiting
for long-running operations.
Google Cloud IAM
makes it even easier
to manage permissions so
you don't need to worry
about unauthenticated requests.
Workflow also gives
you full visibility
into what's happening.
You can see each step execute
as your workflow handles errors,
retries, and recovers
from failures, even
for third-party APIs.
Plus, Workflow executes with
low latency and no cold starts
with fully-managed
scaling, making them
ideal for event-driven tasks.
If your workflow is a batch
orchestration workflow
for data engineering
or ETL, you may
want to look at Google Cloud
Composer, built on a Apache
Airflow with data analysis
focus integration.
It's built for workflows
involving data analysis.
On the other hand,
if your workflow
is focused on orchestrating
work done by services,
Cloud Workflow delivers a fully
managed, easy-to-use solution.
Bring your
mission-critical workflows
to Google Cloud Workflows
to discover how quickly you
can deploy powerful solutions,
while knowing everything
will scale operate reliably
in a fully managed,
cost-effective environment.
Check out
cloud.google.com/workflows
to learn more and to
try it out yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]